local ac companies say this is the time
of year when they get the most calls for
service and a lot of those issues can be
prevented with the right maintenance
sasha loftis joins us live tonight with
some important tips sasha
denise and brian as it gets hotter and
hotter out there our air conditioning
units have to work harder and if they go
out it can be dangerous we spoke to an
expert tonight who shared tips to keep
you safe this summer
it's that time again to crank up your ac
and get out of the heat this is when the
phone calls come in the mercury will
keep rising this month well into the
triple digits so keeping your air
conditioning running is crucial we're
ready for it just like everyone else is
brad dworkin owns eight hack heating and
cooling and says every summer his team
sees a 60 to 70 percent increase in
calls these units are challenged from
day one living in las vegas henderson
area he tells us air conditioners are
only made to handle around 95 degrees so
when we get into the one teens they're
more likely to have problems just don't
neglect your unit
it's out there working we're inside
trying to cool off that's why it's
important to have a professional check
it out every year but you can do some of
that maintenance yourself like changing
the air filter frequently you just take
it from the top of the coil and rinsing
the coils to keep it clean and cool
and if your unit does stop working turn
off your thermostat sometimes the units
ice up
we want to make sure they're in
diagnosable condition when we get there
and get to a cool place
to keep you and your family safe you
have to have an ac
brad also said to keep your thermostat
around the same temperature through the
summer day and night whether you're home
or not that is easier for the ac to
maintain that temperature as opposed to
turning it off and turning it back on
when it's hotter outside reporting live
tonight sasha loftis live local now